This project is already split in some
virtual folders that will get us
thinking about the Model view and
Controller.
The AppDelegate and the GCDBlackbox have
been place outside of this folders and
we can ignore them for now.
In the Model folder, we have this
clients folder and then under Clients,
we have TMDB for the movie database.
This folder structure represents
the idea that we could have multiple
clients or managers that handle all the
code related to an API, but since we're
only working with the movie database,
we just have the single TMDB folder, but
you could imagine others like one for
Flickr or Facebook or so forth.
Now in the TMDB folder, we have SWF
files that pertain to the main model of
our project, the TMDB movie as well
as the API's configs, constants and
a TMBD client that will handle all
the communications with the API itself.
We'll talk about this more later.
You'll also notice there's this
one controller-like file called
TMBDOffViewController.
We've designated this file as part of
the model instead of the controller,
because it's used specifically for
the movie databases off-flow and
nowhere else.
But that was just our design decision,
it doesn't have to be this way.
If we look inside the TMDBClient file,
we see that the client is
only partially implemented.
These two methods here
are still commented out.
Here at the top, we've moved
the authentication state into this class
instead of it being in the app delegate
like it was in my favorite movies.
And if we scroll to the bottom,
we have some helper methods.
And at the very bottom,
we have a method that allows us to
use this client like a singleton.
So, in a very similar way as to
how we use the AppDelegate in
My Favorite Movies.
Now these two empty methods at
the top called taskForGETMethod and
taskForPostMethod.
The purpose of these methods is to
reduce the common code in our request
and you've probably noticed that
there's a lot of common code between
each network request
that we've been making.
We also have this
TMDBConvenience.swift file,
which you'll be adding code to as well.
Now let's look at the View,
it contains a single file
called Borderdbutton.swift.
Now some of you may be thinking,
what gives?
Shouldn't this folder
contain our storyboards and
media files since they are what
the user sees, they are the View.
Well, you could do it that way and
it's really up to you, but
we've decided to keep our NBC
folder split and organization or
we're just focusing on the SWF files and
not the other associated media files.
Our reasoning for this is because
most of the actual view classes
have already been built by Apple and
are packaged together inside of UIKit.
And in that way, we've decided that
this View folder over here should only
contain custom code of ours
that is purely view-related.
So in this case, the only custom UI code
that we have is this BorderedButton.
Finally, let's talk
about the controllers.
This folder contains classes that
touch a little bit of the view and
a little bit of our model.
I'll start with the loginViewController.
This class is a prime candidate for
why our previous app,
My Favorite Movies was so
poorly designed.
In this controller, we have four methods
for the four different steps that
are require for the movie
databases authorization flow and
you'll note that the log in with
token uses the new step to A,
which we're going to
cover more detail later.
But we have the getRequestToken,
then loginWithToken, which is step two.
GetSessionID and then the user ID isn't
really part of the authorization flow,
but we get the user ID ahead of time,
so that we can
use it with requests like adding and
removing movies from favorites.
Now each of these methods,
let me blow one of them out right here.
Each of these methods has
a lot of duplicate code and
they make this controller
a really big and heavy class.
I think, let's see,
we're at 340 lines right now.
So, it's starting to get pretty large.
But what's worse is that if want to add
more complexity, this controller is
just going to keep growing and growing
and become really hard to deal with.
And when you have big files like
this and lots of duplicate code,
then you know you have problems.
What we should be thinking about is
how we make our code light, clean and
reuseable not overly complex and
hard to manage?
For our apps, a great way to fix
this problem is to always keep our
view controller small by
migrating a logic like this,
this networking code
away into the model.
So for this application,
we're going to take the code that's
in this login view controller and
move it into the model or into the movie
database client, this TMDB client.